a 70 year old woman has just died inside
the shreveport louisiana hospital she'd
been here four days battling covet 19.
now nurses prepare her for the funeral
home
i don't think anybody ever told me you
had me taken bodies down to the loading
docks
we've seen a lot of deaths
doctors and nurses across the united
states are struggling under the burden
of a fourth wave of hospitalizations and
deaths driven by the delta variant and
the close to 40 percent of americans who
remain unvaccinated most of the feeling
is just anxiety
exhaustion and just not knowing when
this is going to end
in the state of mississippi some 2
thousand nurses have quit since the
pandemic it's it's every day i mean just
people can't take it's not because they
don't want to do a good job
we've made it really hard for them with
this influx to our health care system
the doctors and nurses in this emergency
room are trying to manage three times
the amount of patients that they saw
prior to this surge that means people
are receiving care in hallways and in
waiting rooms anywhere they can be seen
the staff here calls this a constant
marathon
disheartened and demoralized many are
resigning retiring or taking lower
paying jobs to distance themselves and
the memories of fighting the virus i see
these people over and over again
when i try and sleep
this mississippi nurse has turned in her
resignation
to watch this person deteriorate
and ultimately die alone in a hospital
bed
to watch the culmination of someone's
life i just i can't
take it anymore
staff shortages in louisiana hospitals
have required some doctors to double up
as nurse's aides right now the state has
6 000 vacant nursing job openings
there's no doubt
that being overwhelmed over 17 straight
months
and not being able to spend time with
your family the only natural reaction
for our teams is the struggle
many have begged in vain for more people
to get vaccinated or blame themselves
for not being convincing
now some are just fed up and done while
still more though exhausted and
overwhelmed press on heidi joe castro al
jazeera
let's bring in our white house
correspondent kimberly halkett live in
washington kimberly where do things
stand right now
in terms of numbers
yeah numbers not looking good for the
biden administration that is still
trying to turn the corner on this and
thought that they had with respect to
the infections in the united states
there are now 40 million confirmed cases
in the united states since the start of
the pandemic about 18 months ago and of
that more than 650 000 people have died
now
in terms of the vaccination numbers more
than half the population roughly 53
percent has been vaccinated but
that really only amounts to 176 million
people in other words there are millions
that are still not vaccinated in the
united states and that is what is
causing a problem because uh this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated now
according to biden administration
officials so uh they're very concerned
as the delta
variant continues to spread through the
united states what's happening is
they're seeing the number of deaths
rising as well because
back in june it was less than 300 a day
now it's more than 1900. and so what's
the biden administration doing to
address this kimberley
well they'll be addressing it
specifically the president will on
thursday he is going to be addressing
the nation announcing a sick six-pronged
approach to dealing with this it's
apparently going to have a range of
initiatives across the public as well as
private sector uh the concern is in all
of this is that many of the vaccines
that this administration has been
pushing aren't that effective it's
for example the pfizer vaccine the
modern vaccine and so we expect that
there will be an announcement too about
boosters and what that will look like
who needs to get it and so on but in all
of this there is another problem for the
biden administration that is there is
waning confidence that this president
has this under control in fact two
different polls seem to suggest that
americans have lost faith in the
president's ability to handle this
pandemic his approval rating on that is
down 10 10 points and also we should
point out that when it comes to them
feeling he has a strong message on this
that 42 percent of americans believe he
lacks clarity so he's going to need that
clarity come thursday
to really get that confidence back and
and have americans feel that this is
really turning around the way he
promised many months ago kimberly thank
you very much kimberly harkett live for
us there in washington